not far from chocolate and cocoa avenues
in Pennsylvania American chocolatier
Hershey experiments down these halls
with a well-known confection you know
what this is this is a Hershey kiss it
was first produced in 1907 but more than
a hundred years later we're getting a
high-tech take on this traditional piece
of chocolate and the magic is happening
right in here
one hour 26 minutes the time to 3d print
one Hershey kiss the chocolates beating
heat up up there in this white cabinet
here right and it's pushed through that
small muscle shapes in three dimensions
computer designed then extruded like
icing out of a bag layer on layer
industrial firms have used such methods
with metal plastic and other media since
the first commercial 3d printer in 1989
by 3d systems only recently has food
been tried I don't think I ever foresaw
that we would someday 3d print in
chocolate Geoff Mont has had a
quarter-century career in cocoa 3d
printing says could disrupt the
chocolate making industry for the better
from mass production to mass
personalization so you could potentially
have micro manufacturing facilities that
would create every chocolate bar candy
bar in your in your range all in the
same place and it's no secret the CIA is
testing 3d food printing - not the spy
agency The Culinary Institute of America
in Hyde Park New York
in the same corridors of high-end
culinary creation they're printing
geometric sugar designs and more that
could one day be put on your plate the
printer doesn't think in three
dimensions drinks in cross sectional
two-dimensional layers right the CIA 3d
prints inside a tray of sugar the end
result here a red dyed vase you can eat
we've created a small little geometric
bytes
we've also printed other designs I'm
tasked to take them out it's like
excavating for dinosaur bones activities
are made of sugar and you can eat them
extract the extra sugar with the tiny
airgun gently I broke one Oh No here we
go and then the taste it was like a
solid cinnamon Dolce latte melting in my
mouth but these sweet little blocks are
just the start if you're gonna redo that
Thomas Vacarro is Dean of the CIA we can
move into the world of savory and so
thinking through that there's a
possibility of us dehydrating vegetables
parsnips beets strawberries tomatoes
savories are on the menu elsewhere in
the world like with a consumer forward
foodini
in Spain which prints burgers and the
cheese and pizza and tomato sauce its
first u.s. office is planned for this
year the CIA will open a new 3d food
kitchen and classroom space for chefs in
Los Angeles this year too and her she
will have 3d printed chocolate you can
buy by year's end imagination is the
limit for Hershey it's starting with the
kiss